oh I don't feel appreciated ladies this
one's for you
[Music]
holla oh what is going on YouTube check
it out so last week I put up a video of
a girl who I like to call uh do who you
like me no and from that video and
learning from your comments apparently
women of today you all just don't
appreciate yourself enough and no matter
how many times someone tells you that
you don't need a man to validate your
beauty apparently uh as somebody put it
it don't mean [__] apparently you need
to hear from a man himself either in
flesh or in this case a video so for
those of you ladies who need to hear a
little something from a man to feel
special about yourself uh baby girl I'm
here to do that for
[Music]
you David you don't know what it's like
to be a girl and to never be hit on once
in your
life God damn girl you f hold up the way
you off to Baby y girl you must be on a
steady die a hot damn what side of hell
yes girl you are so f I beat the [__]
out of some oyers to make you a pearl
necklace huh what was that is that is
that the sound of some angel's wings
girl cuz your must be from Heaven tell
you something just give me a half a
bottle of Vaseline and a box of wine
I'll rock your world girl all these
girls have special stories about guys
who who wrote poetry to them or or sung
to them that's never happened to
me you got fashion and style I'm digging
your smile and the way you get down oh
all the pretty girls with the blond hair
and the big boobs well they get the best
man huh you sure about that one but your
self-esteem would have been shot too if
you never been asked out on a
date uh excuse me would you like to go
on a date sometime my fair
lady I don't even get asked out by ugly
ass
dudes I I can't help you out with that
one ngabo where you at ngabo no God has
ever confessed his love to
me hey can I talk to you for a second um
look uh this is a little weird for me um
I have had a crush on you for the past
year now and um you know I'm always a
little bit afraid of rejection so I
never really approached you but
um I want you girl I want your bed
anyways that's about it for those of you
ladies who needed this here you go and
does it really make you feel better
ladies y'all might not give a [__] but
here's a little bit of advice baby girl
if you do not appreciate yourself or
love yourself how do you expect someone
else to oh and here's another thing for
those of you girls out there that have
been saying oh my God you don't know
what it's like when all these blonde
dumb bimbos with big boobies get these
guys shame on you cuz there are plenty
of nice guys out there you know that are
6' tall you know chubby and Korean with
a great
[Music]
personality excuse me uh My Fair Lady
where are you off to this fine night can
I
holler